Okay, sad story time. So, in the early days of
Reddit, I stored passwords in cleartext, because when I was
writing Reddit, I didn't think anybody would actually use it,
let alone a lot of people. So, as we grew, I
had this little bird in my ear telling me, you
know, this is bad, you should fix this, you should hash
these passwords. I knew better, but I didn't because we
actually got some benefit out of clear text passwords. When spammers
would come to Reddit, they would create thousands of accounts, but they
would use the same password for every account. So I was able to
catch these huge webs of spammers. Now the downside of this, is
if somebody had stolen my laptop. I'd be in trouble. And sure enough,
somebody stole my laptop, and I had all of Reddit's usernames and
clear text passwords on it, and I got in a lot of trouble
over that. Now, this would've been an easy fix and it turns
out, you know, after that it was an easy fix. We just went
through and hashed all the passwords like we should have,
but it's very important that you, as a developer, take care
of the user's data, because. They use the same password on
lots of sites, they probably don't really know better and, you
know, it's easier for them to be lazy than for you
to be lazy because you can solve it for everybody. So,
always hash your passwords take care of your user's stuff and
you won't regret it like I did once upon a time.